[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it is the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host Jade
warshaw joined by George camel and today
we are taking calls about your life your
money so give us a call the number is
8825 5225 George let's go directly to
these phone lines do we got Austin and
Omaha Nebraska what's going on
Austin oh not a lot how are you today
I'm doing good how are you I'm doing
very well thank you for asking you bet
just feel blessed to be to have the
opportunity to speak with you about our
financial situation right now it's my
honor so we've been watching uh a lot of
the Show recently and um we're actually
100% out of debt right
now and we're feeling really fantastic
about it and we're also having
some some anxiety about what do we do
next because we have our emergency fund
saved up we allotted 2,000 per person
we've got six months worth of living
expense saved up for our current
situation which we're
renting okay but we want to into a house
and we don't know at this point in the
game do we just sit and stack cash and
then wait until we can just go buy a
house outright or do we stack enough
cash for down payment and then get into
a house as quick as possible yeah that's
a really good question I I have a
question for you before I give you my
answer to your question when you said
that you had an emergency fund you said
$2,000 per person can you elaborate on
what that
meant oh sure um our understanding was
that we needed to have for like um small
medical emergencies about $1,000 per
person and then on top of that we needed
six months worth of household bills and
expenses interesting so we saved 2,000
per person and then on top of that six
months worth of household bills okay
well that's an interesting thought the
way we teach it here at Ramsay is just
to save three to six months of your
basic household expenses so that if you
were to come on Hard Times maybe you
lose a job you have a medical emergency
that would be enough to you know get you
through until you're back on the other
side of things so you know the 4,000
extra you have saved as far as I'm
concerned you can throw that over to the
down payment and start you know you've
got $4,000 saved already to go towards
that and as far as whether or not you
want to buy a home outright or if you
want to save you know 20,000 or as much
as you can save to put down that's
really up to you and your wife what are
you know what's the going rate for a
home that you think will be right for
your
family well wow that's really that's a
that's a tough question we've been we've
been looking at um the different values
of houses and then plugging in the
numbers and you know at if we were going
to go on the 15year fixed like um like
we're seeing that you're teaching then
our our approximate price range is going
to be right around
175k are their homes for 175k
25% pardon me sir are there homes for
175k in your
area uh there are it's I mean it's our
first house we're we'll be first time
home buyers so cool it's nothing that
we're really going to want but we know
that we're going to have to have well
here's the deal if you're like hey the
250 home is the goal well all that means
is patience we're going to save up more
down payment so that we can afford this
and stay within those parameters yeah
what's your
income um combined we are slightly over
100k a year okay and how much can you
throw every month toward down payment
savings currently
well we haven't discussed exactly what
we could throw at specifically that
savings but our margin after our budget
is
$1,469 a month great are you guys
investing at all right
now no we withdrew completely out of our
401ks actually just as of yesterday so
we could start channeling all of our
money straight into a high yield Bings
account so you're wanting to do baby
step 3B full on hey we're not going to
invest at all but for the next year or
two we're just going to pile up cash to
get into that
home yeah that was the idea we just
weren't sure if we should pile up just
enough to get in or what the well at
this rate I wouldn't aim to try to pay
for housing cash because it's going to
be a moving Target and it could take you
10 years so I'd rather you get to the
point where you can do that 15year fixed
rate 25% of take- home pay going towards
the mortgage that's when you know it's
the right time to
buy okay that's actually the the exact
discussion we had last night I said I
think what we need to find out tomorrow
is whether or not we're going to be here
in the apartment for two years or 10
yeah and if it's going to be more than
two I would start investing I would too
you could do both
simultaneously maybe start out by saying
okay for the like George said for the
next year year and a half up to two
years we're just going crazy putting all
of our money to this down payment but
maybe once you hit that t two-year Mark
if you're not ready to pull the trigger
and you're like you know what we've got
this much saved it'd be great if we
saved you know x amount of dollars more
I'd go ahead and start investing and
then try to reach that savings at the
same time that way you're not missing
out on valuable time um and compound
interest what do you think about that
pretty powerful force right absolutely
when it's going in the right direction
so just doing some math for you the
right direction yes 1,700 bucks a month
is 20 grand a year so in two years you'd
have 40 Grand and let's say it's a
$200,000 home that's 20% down that would
give you $160,000 mortgage and you can
use our mortgage calculator on our
website to start figuring out all right
are we going to be within this range and
if it's 26% we're not going to going to
yell at you the whole point of that is
not to be legalistic it's to make sure
that you're not house poor and you have
50% of your take-home pay going towards
the
mortgage amen how's that hit
you that hits me like a like a pretty
solid plan excellent awesome I love it
we got him out of analysis paralysis
mode that's right that was a great call
I think uh George A lot of people are in
that situation uh with the market the
way it is it's almost like even when
people have done the math it's like we
can save for this a lot of people I've
talked to have already saved the money
and they're just sitting on it because
they're afraid to get into the market
because interest rates are high uh
inflation is High student loans are
coming back and it's like do I pull the
trigger is it smart to buy a home it's
like there's all this uneasiness around
a subject and so true well it's interest
rates and the housing Market's insane
the best time to buy a house is when
you're ready financially to buy a house
and so that's why we have those
parameters you don't have to wait on the
sidelines and wait for some magical
perfect interest rate or wait foring
Market to crash you might be waiting a
long time a long time and by then you're
mad at us cuz you're like the house
prices are triple now I'm like right
sorry and I know a lot of people are
worried you know obviously interest
rates on average have hit over 8% and
it's like now's you know I'm just going
to wait I'm going to wait it I'm like no
if you have the money go buy like get
into the market if interest rates go
down enough that it makes sense free to
refinance you'll always have the
opportunity to do that but you don't
like you said you don't want to sit on
the sidelines get in the game because
whatever property you have if you buy
smart it is still going to go up in
value over time and you've got to get
into the market so that you can start
being a part of the game and adjusting
how everybody else is right if you just
sit out there and you're renting forever
not to mention rent goes up too you know
that's true and a lot of people were
freaking out remember it wasn't long ago
we had bidding wars and before it even
hit the market it was gone well the
Market's cooled down a little bit now
you can actually take your time you
might be able to even have a really
great offer below asking price and get
it and so if you're on the sidelines
it's time you know hit up our friends at
Churchill Mortgage get preapproved start
the process start house hunting with a
Ramsey trusted real estate agent all of
these things are going to help you get
out of that analysis paralysis that's
right your rent your mortgage that
payment is usually people's highest
payment right and you don't want that
fluctuating your whole life with rent we
know that home buying is the key to
Building Wealth this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks Dr John delone here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become healthy habits
like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with a daily practice of meditation and
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey this is the Ramsey Show I'm your
host Jade warshot to my right is George
camel give us a call the number is 8825
5225 and we will discuss the things that
are on your mind as it relates to your
life your money your career what's going
on in your world but before we get to
that we've got our neighborly question
of the day our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when emergency repair
needs pop up at home the last thing you
want to do is spend time searching for
the right providers I know that's right
the neighborly app helps you find the
top local home service providers like
airserve Mr rder plumbing and more don't
wait until something goes wrong be ready
now download the neighborly app today
today's question comes from Mark in New
York he asks I'm currently around
$360,000 in debt $260 on the house and
$100,000 in credit cards I feel beyond
help with my debt I'm struggling with
what to do the minimum payment on all
the credit cards equates to more than I
make on a monthly basis it feels
hopeless I don't know how to get out of
the situation I've put my family in
please help all caps oh Mark I can't
breathe just reading that question man
I'm so sorry to hear that I mean
$100,000 in credit card debt that's a
very special type of debt and that I
mean very high interest and uh it's
going to take a while to climb out and
Jade you had six figures in debt so you
can speak directly to this but it's
different when he's going I make it's
more than I make on a monthly basis yeah
which means we got to make more he's got
to make more and you know I think
mentally if he can just for just for a
moment separate his home mortgage from
the the the whole total less
overwhelming it's less overwhelming and
the good thing is your your home is
making money for you hope you know the
market will accumulate more equity for
you so let's put the home of 260 on the
back burner for now you'll get to that
much longer down the lane and let's look
at this 100,000 now here's what I would
cuz George was right uh Sam and I were
in a position where our bills were far
more than what we had to pay and so you
you have to get on the phone you have to
get on the phone with these folks and
say look here's what's going on unless
you make this payment XYZ you're not
going to get any money and so you've got
to call these people up and let's for
now negotiate very small payments
because we're going to make minimum
payments on everything in our debt
snowball right and we're going to put
any and all extra money to the smallest
debt so not only do we need to find
extra income we've got to find margin
actually put more on a smallest debt so
first things first you're getting on the
phone making those calls and here's the
thing I hate credit card companies
they're going to tell you no that's not
possible and the only way is you've got
to you know make one payment today and
just give us your credit you know give
us your bank account information and
we'll do it don't do any of that do not
give them your account information do
not set up a plan just say hey it's
either this or you're not getting it at
all and you want to know what they might
not get it for a while but you're going
to get through this and what you also
need to do on the other side of that is
you've got to find more income Georgia
doesn't say what his income is we got no
clue we don't know what his minimums are
but the other thing he can do is call
and ask them to lower the interest rate
and say Hey listen I'm trying to pay
this off I really am what would be a
huge help is if you could lower this
interest rate so that I can give you the
money that I owe I love that and thank
you cuz you just joged my memory George
I remember getting on the phone with
Capital One and saying look if you look
back through all of my payment history I
probably have X amount of dollars in
late fees and over you know over usage
fees can you just refund some of those
can you just do me a solid and they did
and a lot of times they did a lot of
times they didn't but here's the thing
it doesn't hurt to ask all you can do is
ask ask for a lower interest rate ask if
they'll forgive some of the fees and and
finally ask if you can have a lower
payment temporarily because you're on a
plan and you're paying off the debt
and after that you just got to get your
inome come up yeah and I don't know what
kind of debt I mean 100 Grand in credit
cards is a insane amount so I don't know
what you purchased on that if it was
we're trying to get by before it was
couches and cars and who knows what but
I'm going to go what out of that money
can I return can I sell to try to undo
some of this stupid tax that I've
created here that could help as well
last ditch effort he could look at
selling the house I don't like that it
feels like a it's almost the scapegoat
option of like I didn't really have to
change my behavior I could sell the
house use the equity and pay off the
debt I would rather see him increase his
income and climb out of this thing
versus get rid of his house I agree
because and I'm not trying to be
judgmental but when I see $100,000 of
credit card debt it makes me ask serious
questions about your behavior and what's
been going on in life like I've got a
lot of questions and so I would love to
see him walk through that um I wish we
knew what his income was but whatever it
is questions it gots to go up right call
call us up we'll talk more all right
let's go to Monica she's in Hanford
Stockton California what's going on
Monica Hi how are you guys doing today
doing fine how are you good um so my
question is kind of like a career
question uh I am a dental hygienist of
eight years and as much as I love what I
do I love educating uh patients and
bonding with patients especially when
they have fear uh it's turning towards
more of becoming a
salesperson and kind of pushing things
on patients when I don't necessarily
feel they need it ooh and I took um Kim
Coleman's career assessment because I am
on maternity leave but I'll be going
back in November and I've been having
some doubts going back um with his
career assessment it highlighted that I
am good at being an educator and
coaching and since I started your guys'
plan I've actually gotten really into it
and uh being being a financial coach
seems to be like a good idea to me so I
want to know how do I transition even
though I love what I do how do I
transition from that and then possibly
balancing out and becoming uh a
financial coach yeah maybe you know I'm
having two thoughts um number one is I'm
just wondering about the actual office
that you're working in as a dental
hygienist um I had a I had a buddy who
loved dental hygiene and the way her
office was training
all of the hygienists it it did turn
more into a sales rle it was like they
were all like continually pushing things
and products on the customer and she was
like I don't like this and she found
another office that didn't do that and
so she was able to focus on the
attributes of her job that she did love
and for her it was just as simple as
switching offices so that's my first
question and I even wonder if that's
step one and then as you do that you can
start to build the financial coaching
thing on the side and get that to a
place and start you know building into
that and putting time into that and then
if you're like hey I really love this it
starts making money for you you'll have
that moment where you can kind of switch
over because there's a bridge
there yeah that's yeah that's good
advice um I've tried different offices
and it
seems
to keep gearing in the same after a
couple months gearing in that in that
way of we need more production we need
more production but um yeah I could keep
looking
and and keep trying different offices
this is probably out of the eight years
my sixth office Wow have you let your
Your Leader your dentist know say Hey
listen I'm not comfortable pushing this
stuff I'm happy to do dental hygiene
that's what I signed up for but I don't
I can't in good faith push these credit
cards and payment plans on to people and
have you brought that up to
them um I have mentioned it uh anything
that I kind
of mentioned to them it seems to just
okay we'll address it later and it goes
underneath the underneath well what
happens if you just don't push the
credit cards what would
happen if I didn't um they probably
recognize that I'm the one person not
doing it and probably talk to me from
time to
time but having that outside pressure of
feeling it just
seems I don't know unethical I don't
know I don't like that yeah I think if
it's not needed there's there's a
difference between knowing what the
patient needs and me feeling strongly
about that and educating them and having
and doing it what's best for them
absolutely no one's the saying you got
to treat them based on their needs not
what a general here's a package deal get
all of it well you work with integrity
and that's great I mean that's the type
of person I'm looking for in a dent
hygienist right there so I think that
that's incredible uh the thing I'm
worried about is I don't want you
leaving this job without something
prepared for you so whenever we talk
about going from a situation where
you've got like the steady income George
and it's like hey I want to build this
business over here you've got to play
those cards correctly because you don't
want to just quit and then you're like
that is not the position that you want
to build a business we don't want this
to be a giant leap of faith we want it
to be just a step off the dock right
into the boat right there so build that
business I'd start pouring into that now
start getting your feet wet start
getting the training you need and start
building that up so that it's there when
you're ready to make the leap this is
the ramsy
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew through it's
scaled with us net week worked for ramsy
and it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34,000
customers who trust netw Suite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this is the Ramsey Show I am
Jake warshaw this is George camel and we
every month do a series of budgeting
webinars because George some of the
biggest questions we get is how am I
supposed to budget my income is
irregular or how am I supposed to stick
to my budget or my spouse sticks to my
budget I don't stick to the budget or
vice versa and people need help with
this oh 100% And we can't go through
this on radio and so to have an hour
where you can visually see us going
through every dollar showing you how it
works showing you how to create that
margin the response has been amazing
incredible like it's amazing how many
people sign up for these webinars month
in month out we usually do about two a
month George you host some I host some
uh Rachel Cruz hostes hosts them and we
have one coming up October 24th it's a
Rachel Cruise every dollar webinar I
might sign up for that just to get some
tips okay that's what I'm thinking and
I'm thinking you need to sign up for it
too if you've had any questions about
budgeting and I'm telling you they're
great they're completely informal
they're over your lunch break you can do
it while you eat your Jimmy Johns while
you eat your Firehouse Subs no one is
going to judge you if you have your te
Rachel's favorite I found this out
SCH I don't know anyone who's ever said
that word who's ever been there but
she's a big fan so look every dollar
budgeting all you have to do to sign up
is go to Every
doll.com budgeting Tove your spot I love
it let's go to the phone lines we got
Kim in Baltimore Maryland what's going
on
Kim hi um so we have been about two
months into our debt snowball we're
making really good progress but the
thing my husband and I are buting heads
about is whether or not we should stop
contributing to is 401K because his
employer matches his
contributions yeah that's a toughy he
feels like we're losing out on free
money um but I also feel like hey this
is you know really going to impact our
snowball here at 100% hold on he's
giving away money to lenders every month
he's clearly not that
concerned that's true so let's just make
it clear if we're going to start doing
math about hey we're we're losing out on
this money yeah to the debt and so this
is a tough one I I totally understand I
empathize with those who are nerds like
me who are like why wouldn't you take
the it's 100% return you guys are always
telling people to start with the match
and how great that is but we also know
that getting out of debt is hard and it
takes some Behavior change and you need
momentum and you need progress and when
you draw that line of the sand you go
you know what that extra $400 we were
investing that what is the match can you
tell me the
number so right now he we've already
he's already agreed drop it down to
their the maximum that they will match
so it's at 400 so we put in 400 they put
in 400 okay can I tell you that if you
just invest 400 bucks a month you may
have a great retirement but what if you
could invest $1,000 a month 1,500 a
month that's what happens when you free
up those debt payments and pausing your
match going down to zero lights a fire
under you to then get out of the debt so
you can get back to investing to then
invest way more than the measly
match yeah so that's hard if I just told
him that to his face he'd still go yeah
but it's free money right yeah no
completely yeah yeah you know I agree
with George wholeheartedly some you know
when we find ourselves in debt we look
up and it's like oh man I made a mess
I've got to get myself
out sometimes we have to pay the
consequence of that and in this case
it's you don't get to invest yet you
know you get to clean up your mess then
when the time comes you get to put more
in like George said than you ever
dreamed of and the the time here's the
here's the key and I want everybody
listening to get this and Kim this is
not you but if you're going to
dilly-dally with these baby steps if
you're going to you know uh I'll put a
little here and a little there and
you've paused your retirement you are
jacking yourself because you're not
going quickly the point is I'm going to
do this I'm going to do it with
intensity I'm going to do it quickly
most people are done in under two years
right and so in the grand scheme of
things when you're finally able to
invest 15% and more you know in baby
step seven you are going to more than
make up for whatever you lost in your
match over those two years but if you're
the person who's you know kicking that
can you got hands in your pockets and
it's like well today I'll do it and then
tomorrow I won't it depends on you know
what's on sale then yeah you're going to
jack yourself but the key here is
intensity I think Kim that's what you've
got to go home and explain to your
husband is like look I get it it's a
match it's free money but we've got to
clean up our mess first and the quicker
we clean up our mess the quicker we can
get to the things that we want to do the
fun part and let's be honest investing
is the fun part that's it cam how much
debt do you guys
have uh so right now we are at a
combined total of 22,000 in debt we've
got 6,000 in a home impr improvement
loan and 16,000 in credit card debt okay
um and currently we're after all of our
um like medical expenses uh gas
groceries all that stuff and our
mortgage we're putting 2,000 a month
toward our debt great so we're looking
at and we're currently looking at at an
11 month payoff but if we can add that
400 in we're looking at a N9 month
payoff and and what if one or both of
you get a side hustle and what if you
decided you know what if you make the
sacrifice and go down to 0% I'll make a
sacrifice in this area so I've got some
skin in the game too and all of a sudden
you have four five6 $700 going towards
this debt you didn't have before now
you're at of debt in 7 months instead of
11 and you see that that progress to go
hey 7 months from now if you follow this
to a te we'll be back to investing way
more than we were s months prior and
then start doing the math on what credit
card interest is doing to you as you
lose out on the extra 400 bucks you
could have been putting towards that
payment yeah if he wants to do some math
we can do math so we did the debt
snowball way back 10 years ago we first
got married paid off 40 Grand in student
loans and then we just fell off and as
you often do and I'm like okay you know
what we have to do and and we didn't
contribute to a 401 K while we were
still in student loan debt and he knows
that I'm like why was that okay back
then I think you were younger I think
you were younger and he was like yeah
we've got time and probably now that you
guys are you know you're into this and
it's further he's like oh you know he's
starting to look at the future and go
we've got to get there's things that
need to happen and he it sounds like
he's got good motives like he wants to
do what's right for his family do it
logically we can't just land on logic we
have to think about behavior and emotion
what got us in here we got to do
something about cuz you've been through
it before so the fact that you fell back
in you got to tell them listen this is
insane that we're back here we made
progress then we took a step back once
and for all we're going to be done with
this and that means going all in yeah I
love that that's a good call Kim thank
you for the call I think a lot of people
face that and I think that's probably
one of the toughest um parts of the baby
steps for controversial yes the amount
of flak we get I can't believe they tell
people to stop them listen life isn't
all always just about a number in a
match yes we've got to look at the the
big picture and the big picture is most
Americans are investing 3 or 4% to get
the match and that's it and that's what
they do their whole life and we're
telling you hey for a year or two go
down to zero so you can go back up to 15
and can I be I'm I'm going be I'm going
to put some folks on blast right quick
cuz here's what I think here's what Jade
thinks I think people don't want to stop
their investment contribution because if
they can say yes but I've got x amount
in savings or x amount in retirement
then they don't feel so bad about this
debt that they have sitting over here
and it's like well I still you know I
still have a positive net worth because
I've been investing to my 401 C like
yeah but you still have $40,000 in debt
or $6,000 in debt and so I think for a
lot of people it's their little Jedi
mind trick to make them think they're
doing better than they actually you what
this is though it's really a toddler
mindset the toddler says hey why eat my
vegetables when the cake is buy one get
one free let's just skip to the dessert
Jade got a great deal on cake right now
why do I have to eat my vegetables well
you're going to be realiz out of shape
and have a tummy ache that's right and
that's what we are as a country right
now yeah the entire country is just
broke and in debt not investing enough
up to their eyeballs in Consumer Debt
we're at record levels across the board
credit cards a trillion dollars auto
loans $1.58 trillion student loans $1.57
trillion and yet we're complaining that
you can't build wealth in America today
and we're telling you what if you got
out of debt and invested more and you
could retire with dignity I love that
more even more than dignity I'll take my
BOGO cake Jade no thank you you know
what I call that I call that skinny fat
George have you ever seen people who are
they look skinny but they're diet man
their diet is total crap they eat
McDonald's and they just but somehow
because they have good metabolism or
whatever they're still skinny and I
think that when you are investing it's
like oh I've got this money stacked I've
got savings but you've got this pile of
debt over here it makes it look like hey
I'm in good shape I do what I'm supposed
to do but really your diet is crap and
you're eating McD Donald's and you've
got a bunch of debt stacked over here
and it's when you sweat it's sweating
out of your pores why do you think I'm
wearing all black today Jade it's very
slimming it is very sliming you don't
know what I'm hiding under here I don't
want to know what you're hiding under
that so much McDonald's you know me
that's only for Whitney to discover this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
40% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
you're listening to the ramsy show I am
your host Jade warshaw I'm joined by
George camel who is host of The George
cell show on YouTube which by the way is
popping off George we just hit 100,000
subscribers the other day J I saw that
congrats now I got to beat delone and
Rachel from friendly competition I love
that uh we're having fun yeah if you
have not already hop on over to YouTube
and smash that subscribe button for the
George camel show and by the way you
were on the show we had you on a fun
really fun interview that's right that
was super fun people love Jade on there
so you need to come back I got yeah that
was a lot of fun thanks for having me um
there it is up there on the screen the
George Campbell show if you're watching
on YouTube and for all you who are loyal
listeners to this show the Ramsey show
thank you so much for listening and we
hope that you will share the show with
others the same way that I just just
shared Georgia's show sharing is caring
sharing is caring and we want all of our
friends friends to be rich and out of
debt as well so share the show so that
they can get this wonderful that's they
call this gatekeeping Jade when you
don't tell someone interesting yeah
don't gatekeep is that let people know
that debt freedom is possible yeah that
you can invest the right way and not
fall for all these Tick Tock traps
interesting don't Gaye keep I'm trying
to be young and relevant well Jay-Z said
you're not rich if everybody is if
you're the only one rich and around you
is that you're not really wealthy it's
got to be contagious hanging around
other rich people that's right you got
to be sharing the knowledge sharing the
wealth sharing the blueprint and that's
what we want you to do uh if this show
has changed your life if you like it
maybe you just find it entertaining tell
some people about it hit that little
paper airplane button on Instagram or
share it through YouTube or just like
old school just like talk about it while
you're having lunch and tell somebody
hey there's this this this new podcast
I've been listening to and it's awesome
it's called the ramsy show we would
appreciate that so much it's free and of
course like we said it's spreading that
good good all around the world so in the
meantime let's go to the phone lines
we've got Marie in Durham North Carolina
North Carolina what's going
on hi guys thanks for taking my call
you're welcome how can we
help um so I have a question I just
recently paid off all my debt um about
well $80,000 woohoo um and I um
I didn't go through the baby steps like
a normal person um because I didn't
start until late but um I have so I also
have like a uniform transfer to Miner
account that my parents created for me
when I was younger um and I'm under the
impression that it's just like mutual
funds now okay uh my goal would be to um
buy a town home or something uh in the
near future um and I have about $57,000
in there um I was just wondering if it's
a good idea to use that money as a down
payment on a house um for me I think
that that sounds wonderful um you said
that you didn't walk through the baby
steps in the traditional sense that's
fine uh you don't have any debt and
that's great my next question before you
bought a house would be to make sure
that you've got 3 to six months of
expenses set up do you have that so yes
I also um cash like Cashwise I have
about
$30,000 um2 five of that is in a high
yield savings account and the rest is
just in my checking and then I have um I
paused investing in my uh retirement um
and I have about 7,000 in there I don't
know if I should
resume yeah now but I okay so the 25
that you have in the high yield is that
3 to six months like what what portion
of savings is that for you so that would
be um three to six months of savings for
me um and my goal so I I have
$30,000 um I would just I would want to
save at least um $20,000 for my
emergency fund okay before I buy a house
and I have that um so if 20,000 gets you
to three months or four months or
whatever that part is within the three
to six months which for you let's let's
take that a little bit further okay so
it's just you what type of work do you
do I'm a nurse okay so pretty steady
work pro you're probably okay with 3
months if four months makes you feel
better I'm not mad at that
um typically the way we determine that
is if you're in good health if you have
a stable job uh if you're somebody who's
married what do you what do your job
situations look like that's kind of how
we determine that 3 to six month
situation and I feel like you as a nurse
um I'd probably stick somewhere between
three or four months and i' feel good
about that George yeah and on top of
that have you looked into the tax
implications of withdrawing the
money um I I do know there will be tax
implications um and I just I didn't even
know like if it that just pulling the
money out would even be a good idea just
it's been sitting there for so long that
I just don't even know what to do with
it I'm assuming they save that money
because they wanted to be a blessing for
you later in life as you you know begin
your adult life so I think there's no
time like the present if you're looking
to get into a home and that money is
going to help you do that faster and
you've you followed the principles I
mean you're debt free with an emergency
fund and so Now's the Time to Begin that
down payment savings and if you want to
Stack up as much cash as possible and
that account pay the taxes use all of
that towards a down payment in the next
year or two that's great mhm okay I
didn't yeah that was my plan yeah
because if you add the you know if you
add the 10,000 that you had as an
overage in your savings I mean you're at
60 well you've got taxes on this m taxes
but still you're could be looking at 50
Grand down payment which is awesome how
old are
you 30 okay you got so much time this is
awesome this is yeah consider it a gift
I love that I love it I love when we get
to say yes to people well yeah the the
whole you know the utas and the ugas fun
names they're meant to save for your
child so that when they're an adult
they'll have a little pile of money
which is awesome yeah I'm not mad at
that that's very generous well let's see
what William's talking about in
Anchorage Alaska William thanks for
calling
in hey how's it going we're doing good
how are
you oh not too bad I was just wondering
about uh credit score after paying off
and closing
accounts I there somewhere one Dave
Ramsey said that uh the credit score
will go to zero after like 6 months or
something yeah I was trying to research
that I couldn't find anything on it so
once you finished paying off all your
debts and all of your debts are paid off
and all of your accounts are closed then
that will start the process of your
credit score slowly rolling to zero so
you're going to see it go down first
it's not going to just totally evaporate
you're going to see it go down first and
I'll be honest that is a little bit
emotional and then after time it'll be
zero or indeterminable um for Sam and I
let's see for me I think it took like
seven months and for Sam it took a
little bit longer I've actually heard
people say it's taken almost a year in
some cases six to 12 months is the
average and so if you can also go pull
your credit report for free at
annualcreditreport.com uh that's the one
site where you can do this for free and
you can pull that and see hey look I got
no lines of credit open because a lot of
people think they Clos the lines of
credit that's right the credit score
hangs around and they find out oh I
forgot about that account and you know
what George makes a really good point
William I'll tell you this I was messing
around and looking on creditkarma.com
checking my credit score after we had
paid off all the debts on my name I'm
like ooh I was so excited to see the
score roll to zero and it took it there
forever it just sat at like 300 or
something and it was just like
destroying my my self-esteem and then uh
we started looking at the process of
buying a house and when they pulled my
credit like the real way it was Zero ah
yeah these these sites they're it's kind
of like a Zillow where they're they're
pulling information from somewhere else
that's the official source and it's not
always accurate but more than that
here's what you got to keep in mind
William and anybody else sites like
Credit Karma they want to sell you debt
so they benefit from saying oh your
credit score is 300 let us tell you how
to get that score back up again oh yeah
they'll notify you hey you should open
up this line of credit from us that will
help you get your score up and we have
this new card and there's new loan and
this credit card we partnered with yeah
it's just riddled with loans and debt
and so when anytime that you go well
mint.com is free I'm like yeah cuz
you're the product bro it's not free EX
you're going to get bombarded with debt
and marketing and uh that's that's the
sad underbelly of how these companies
work it is so be aware and just know hey
be patient and like I said it is
emotional George when you see that go to
zero and let me also be clear I actually
made a social post about this a lot of
people they're like I paid off all my
debt but I'm keeping that one credit
card open just as a little you know
safety net or whatever but I'm like no
that's not going to work yet again
George when it comes to this plan you
either got to take it or leave it
because if you start doing Shady stuff
like that it's not going to work for you
everything we teach is being able to
live a life without a credit score and
if you keep that one card around that
you're not utilizing you're not using
it's only going to make your credit
score go down give it up work you can
live without a credit score across the
board renting cars buying a house it's
all possible and we're living proof
that's right we're living proof it's
time to give up the ghost give up those
credit cards let that score go on ahead
and go to zero a zero credit score is
just as good actually it's better than a
good credit score zero is what we're
looking for this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey it's George camel if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsey Baby steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started live from the headquarter of
Ramsey Solutions it is the ramsy show
where we help you build work wealth do
work that you love and create actual
amazing relationships I'm your host Jade
warshaw I'm joined by George camel and
we are taking calls all afternoon about
your life about your money your budget
how to make more money get more income
coming in pay off your debt this is what
we're talking about so give us a call
the number is
5225 we're going to jump in direct IR ly
to the phone lines we've got Tristan in
Dallas Texas what's going on Tristan J
George how are y'all doing we're doing
great how are you I was a the wisest
redneck I know says better than I
deserve I'm glad Dave's not here to hear
that the you might take wisest redneck
that's nice yeah yeah yeah hey hey I'm
I'm a descendant of many a redneck so I
I'm right there there you go there you
go I love it how can we help today yeah
so I'm uh in baby step 2 right now I've
got I've got about $40,000 worth of debt
that's mostly student loans and then a
yeah then I've got a car loan that uh I
well I was recently driving around a
brand new car but I listened to Dave and
sold that and got a cheaper car for the
time being that I just owe about five
grand on now okay great and yeah and so
ah the only credit card that I have is
one credit card that uh I really
discovered about a year ago on Father's
Day when my mom kind of unexpectedly
passed away oh man and yeah and when me
and my uh me and my siblings were
helping my dad go sorry go through
everything and kind of get uh try to get
him sorted out because we knew our mom
handled most of the finances uh we
actually had discovered that she had
opened up I think it was 12 credit cards
in his name and 11 in my name yeah oh my
goodness 11 cards in your hey I'm sorry
that's tough I mean it's tough enough
you lost your mom and then to discover a
secret like that that's painful yeah
yeah it was it was rough for a little
while but thankfully I've got a uh at
the time I had a wonderful girlfriend
who helped me get through it and now
she's my fiance okay so we're gonna get
married soon um but my my main question
is that 10 of the cards I showed them uh
some information reported a claim to
them saying that these are fraudulent
and they like were actually really
helpful immediately closed them out
reported them as fraudulent okay and
there's just one card that initially
told me that oh yeah we're going to
close this out in about a week and then
I found out a few months later that they
were uh they had in fact not closed the
car out and they had been charging me
late fees and it just been yeah did you
get it in writing that they were going
to close it unfortunately no it was all
over the phone yeah and basically we've
been going back and forth for about a
year and turns out the thing that they
are hanging on right now to keep it open
is that when I was 18 uh my mom had
bought me a plane ticket to go visit my
older brother in California as like an
early birthday present okay and she
apparently had done that on that credit
card so there was a plane ticket in my
name so so like hey this isn't fraud
what's balance on it what's the balance
on the card it was about 1,800 but after
the late fees now it's like
2,200 and so part part of me is just
kind of frustrated and just and just
kind of want to be like okay let me
maybe just throw this in the debt
snowball but the other part of me is
just like d NE I'm not I don't want to
let this freaking credit card company
win so what's your
income uh this year it's going to be
91 okay if I'm new this has been a year
of headache and hassle you lost your mom
this is not what you want consuming your
mental space
yeah you know what I mean and it's like
if I don't want to overstep but the
longer that you have to deal with this I
feel like it has the ability to kind of
infiltrate what you're feeling about
your mom even like she left me with this
problem and now I mean uh and it's just
I feel like that has that can be a
really tangled web and you can end up
feeling like some bitterness or like
some anger towards her when really all
you want to do is just grieve your
loss yeah and I definitely felt that for
the for about the first six months after
she passed and yeah went to went to
therapy for it though and so I I really
don't yeah that part I'm not really
holding on to any more because she she
did what she did uh in her in her mind
she thought she was doing what was what
was the best for us and us other kids
but uh yeah so it it that I'm not too
worried about I'm just like yeah I I'm
still gonna pay it George what would you
do I would call and say listen I'm done
with this here's what I'm asking you to
do just cut the late fees cut this 400
bucks off I'm happy to pay the original
balance but we've been fighting this
thing I didn't even know about this card
and so I'll work with you on this but
I'm paying my 1,800 and that's it and
get that in writing and say hey I'm
closing the card after that so that's
what I would fight for but I wouldn't
fight to try to get it to zero over the
next 10 years like Jade said and just
it's too many brain calories yeah yeah
over too small of an amount of money
yeah I agree with that I I second that
notion George that's a good one
appreciate the call Tristan but that
that is tough man you know I hear about
this all the time um and and this is not
what happened in Tristan's situation but
for moms and dads listening it is fraud
if you open up credit cards and the
names of your children like and say that
it's you that's fraud and not only that
like you have the ability to really Jack
their credit I know people personally
who this has been done to them and then
they hit 18 and they get into the world
and they're 21 and 23 and they're like
why do I like why is my credit already
bad like what's happened to me and they
find out it's because their parents have
opened up cards in their you m with your
kids Financial life and the other Trend
I'm seeing Jade I'm seeing the all these
videos on Instagram and Tik Tok there's
all this advice saying hey add your kid
as an authorized user on your card even
if they're 3 years old when they're 18
they're going to have amazing credit and
they're going to be so grateful and
here's what happens the parents blow up
their kids credit Yeah by accident yes
and then screw up their kids's Financial
life before before they're even an adult
it's so unfair it's so unfair you've got
to let your kids decide who they want to
be financially you don't don't just set
them out there and just assume that what
because what if they follow the Ramsay
way and they don't want to have anything
to do with credit and credit cards what
I could only hope I could only dream
that's the case George that's what we're
hoping for but um you've got to be
careful and then there's another
teaching in this George about um if you
are a monitoring Your Own Credit and
making sure you see all the accounts on
there because this is talking about he
said there were 10 accounts uh 11 in his
dad's name and then another 11 accounts
in his name o yeah this is the
importance we are not for the credit
score but we are for pulling your credit
report once a year you can do this on
annualcreditreport.com we have no
affiliation this is just the authorized
Federal website to do this for free and
that will show you every single trade
Line Credit account you have open every
single student loan everything it's
going to lay it all out to give you a
picture and that's how I found out that
fraud had happened to me yeah there was
an AT&T account and a Verizon account
opened across the country with a
previous address of mine in Nashville
wow that was opened and they added 1,700
bucks worth of debt wow onto both of
those accounts and the only way I found
that was pulling my credit report and
getting a collector call saying hey you
owe us this money I went what I didn't
have Horizon yeah so there you go
something like that happened with samon
it was a Discover card and he was like I
don't know what this is I don't know
what it came from and yeah check your
credit score make sure you recognize the
debt and when you do pay it off this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian healthare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all all 50 states so see
if chm could be right for your family
check out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
all right you are listening to the ramsy
show I am Jade warshaw your host joined
by George camel host of The George camel
YouTube show and George um you're big
into social media I'm big into social
media there is a trend that is
circulating that to be honest I can't
tell if I think it's funny or if I'm a
little bit offended but it's called yeah
a little bit of both it's called girl
math so girl math is trending apparently
and I'm not going to tell you what it is
we have a video for you guys to watch
and this kind of explains it so take a
look at this here's a list of things
that I firmly believe because of girl
math anything under $5 is free anything
I buy with a gift card is free if I buy
something but then I return it I've made
money going to an event or a concert is
free because I purchased the tickets so
long ago it like doesn't even count I
load my Starbucks app in advance so
Starbucks is free anything discounted
more than 50% is free and I like am
losing money by not getting it if I'm
like paying someone back for dinner and
I have have money in venmo that dinner
is free if I don't buy something like if
I don't buy a pair of shorts for $50
like I've made $50 and I can then go
spend $50 on something else okay this
one's a little bit weird but my husband
and I share credit cards and a bank
account but somehow every time that he
puts down his card with his name on it
like that's free and he paid wow okay
that moved fast but man that's hilarious
and relatable it's ratchet that's messed
up all of that is so so wrong it's wrong
so here's here's my definition so Rachel
Cruz and I we covered the concept of
girl math on last week's smart money
Happy Hour episode okay at length and it
was eye openening to say the least but
here's our definition all right girl
math is a term for how women justify
unnecessary spending through a series of
mental gymnastics so that's what it
comes down to it's Financial it's money
mental gymnastics yeah that is
gymnastics I mean she just the way they
were rolling off the tongue I was like
wow this is your way of life the weird
thing is I'm let me be 100% honest as a
lady myself there were a couple of the
ones that she said that I I think that I
have rationalized in my own head yes
like what when she was like if it's a
gift card it's free I was like yeah I'm
with that I'm with that if it's a gift
card and you didn't buy the gift card
100% that's free I don't think I don't
know that that falls into girl math cuz
that's you feel like a gift card is free
can we just call this out that the guys
are very much guilty of guy math which
is a whole another thing that's now come
up what's what's man math it involves
more like Home Depot and Lowe's
justification you know the truck
justification why they need a $60,000
truck so they're stupid taxes a lot more
zeros on the end in the girl math but my
wife has been guilty of the of I'm going
to return something and then she'll come
home and say I made I made a $75 I'm
like no that means we just spent the
difference okay can I you spent 200 you
returned 75 you didn't make 75 you spent
125 okay you know what I mean can well
can I tell you my version of that cuz I
think mine's worse uhoh if I like
honestly today I have a return and I has
was already thinking about this look I
know where you're going with this I have
a pair of pants and a shirt to return
and I'm like hey that's going to be like
like $110 and I was already thinking
like if I what I I know what I want to
get and I'm like it's like $140 and I'm
like it's free because I'm like doing a
return even though it's a little bit
more I still feel like your return isn't
going back in the budget you're like
well that gives me 110 bucks I can spend
elsewhere cuz that money was already
spent that's right now I want to call
add a little to it your husband Sam is
in the lobby watching this right now so
you are spilling the tea on yourself he
is giving me a look of distaste he's
like you best not I think that he's even
shaking he's having a whole conversation
through the glass I can't hear you Sam
oh my gosh I don't want to hear what
you're saying right now but girl math
here's the thing I let me tell you a
quick story I had a buddy call me the
other night I'm not going to tell her
name she I won't put her on blast but
she makes tips for a living she called
me up she's like like Jade if I have
this tip money and I go out and buy XYZ
it doesn't count right and I'm like yes
it does she's like yeah but it's like
found money it's like extra money it
doesn't count and I'm like oh boy yes it
does so sometimes I even think if we
have cash like somebody gives you cash
money you get cash back in your pocket
people think I don't have to add that to
the budget I can just outside of the
system it doesn't exist in the Matrix
there's no paper trail that is true Jen
Z had we cuz we're all about hey you
know switch to cash cash envelope it'll
get control your spending and then they
go to cash and they go no this is free
money cuz it never touched my bank
account so my rule is it has to be
reflected in the budget all money
whether it's cash whether it's a return
the return in every dollar you can drag
the return back into the category and
refill it that is true I'm going to have
to pray about that I'm going pray about
that one George on did she talk about
like concert tickets or event tickets in
that one she did she said if you buy it
far in advance it doesn't
count i b months ago so did I really
spend the money yeah cuz by the time you
get to it you're like oh I didn't I
don't have to pay for this CU you
already did I definitely relate to that
wait can I tell you this is I don't know
if this is girl math or just weird math
buying a car in cash I have said this
before and I know people are probably
rolling their eyes out of their head but
when you save up and buy a car in cash I
feel like it feels free like when you go
and buy the car it's like it never
happened wow because you've been putting
this money aside it's been earmarked
over there it's never been part of your
emotional like daytoday money self and
then you just come home with the car and
you're like that joker was free I'm just
saying yeah no that's fair I mean if you
write that if you write that check yeah
and you see that money disappear there's
an emotional piece where you're like
that's
$223,000 that just disappeared from my
bank but you're right in that you're not
going home with a payment you're not
going home with a loan and therefore
mentally you've removed it yeah
emotionally you've already set that
money aside it's already been earmarked
for something else and so I think some
of that is probably where this girl math
takes part you're kind of uh
compartmentalizing your spending you're
already saying this is this that is that
um and you got to be careful especially
here now let's get into some serious
teaching on this I think if you're
especially married you've got to be
careful with girl math guy math because
ultimately what's the purpose of this
are we doing this to keep purchases from
our spouse we're trying to fly
underneath the radar you know Dave said
it and it's so true you come home with
those Target bags and you're like it was
a return but why are you hiding it under
the bed like why are you hiding it in
the back of your closet or keeping it in
the car can I tell y'all I'm put myself
on blasted this is the type of stuff I
used to do I come home and if I'm like
oh Sam is there I would leave the bag
bags like I leave the bag in the car
until when until you can sneak it in
until a more opportune moment moment
George that's what I used to do back in
the day I know that is mischievous look
these women out here better have my back
CU I know all of y'all y'all have done
it too but the point is once we get more
mature once we start having these
conversations with our spouse and once
we say hey like let's share our money
let's do what it takes to you know get
on the same page we have to stop all
this nonsense well the the heart of it
is it's one of the reasons we're broke
it's fun to laugh at and it's relatable
and we all do it but until you can get
above that mental gymnastics and go you
know what this is an unhealthy
justification for me to spend and not
actually deal with the root problem
which is my behavior and me wanting more
than I have being discontent buying
things out of stress or out of
convenience it's part of the reasons
you're not hitting your financial goals
that's right and so it's hilarious to
laugh at and very relatable and I'm not
here to judge those that fall into those
camps like Jade has just admitted but at
some point you got to just be an adult
and go yeah okay I can't do that anymore
and it it it makes you you know you do
have to this has been a interesting
thing for me so Financial Peace
University that's the class that we
teach it's nine weeks it teaches you
everything you need to know about money
and my husband and I coordinated that
class many many times and a lot of times
we would have younger kids in the class
and like in their 20s 20s 21s like that
age and vinmo cash app zel all of those
quick money transaction apps I noticed
that a lot of people keep those apps and
I think that's where a lot of people
pull a lot of quote unquote found money
or girl math or boy math money that
honestly should be added to their
budgets cuz it's like oh I just got this
you know me and my girl went out to
dinner and she just cashaa me that and
I'm like before you know you're going to
look up and have like $300 in cash app
that's real money yeah you're and you're
just cash apping and ven mooing back and
forth to each other with your balances
exactly while not having any money your
bank account yes that's a problem so the
call to action here is let's let's let's
go through this let's look at the cash
apps let's look at the Vinos let's look
at what the return let's make all of our
money actually be all of our money and
let's have that money working for us and
that's where the budget I think is the
solution that's right to curbing the
mental gymnastics girl math and Guy math
and whoever else math yes the budget is
your friend if you don't have a budget
check out the every dollar budget it's
the only budgeting app I use I know it's
the only budget app that George cell
uses you can download it today for free
at every.com this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
Ramsey
[Music]
all right thanks for hanging out with us
this is the Ramsey Show I am your host
today Jade warshot joined by my other
host George camel I'm here too yeah
that's right and you know what let me go
ahead and say this for the people who
are in the comments we're both
hosts great Point what are they saying
in the comments uh whoever I think they
think whoever sits in this chair is the
host and that whoever sits over there
shouldn't talk much that's funny well we
look at it as a we call them drivers
like who's driving the show today but
it's equal co-host the funnier comment
is that people think it's like Game of
Thrones out here and it's like oh Jade's
goingon to take the throne or Rachel's
gonna no Jordan's gonna take we're out
here trying to fill some big old shoes
of dve Ramy I know that's right so there
ain't no Game of Thrones happening here
yes George so I give you permission you
could say as much as you'd like this
show thank you for your permission Jade
let's go to the phone lines we got
Hannah in Colombia Missouri what's going
on
Hannah hey guys thanks so much for
taking my call you're welcome my H my
husband and I are finishing up baby sub
three we have a one-year-old and our
second baby is due in February nice
exciting yeah
yeah uh my husband just started a new
job this week so we are both now working
from home wow we also have a nanny that
we um bring into our house to provide
our child care so it's a full house um
we currently live in a 3bedroom 2100q
foot house we were going to make this
space work however my husband had his
first Zoom call with his CEO this week
and was immediately kicked off the
internet um the strongest internet
signal offered in our neighborhood is
six megabytes oh gosh of us working here
yeah we're in the middle of nowhere wow
um that's like dial oh my
go that's what it feels like sometimes I
want to throw my computer out the window
I
bet so between that hurdle and just
wanting more space with another baby and
us both being here we're wondering if we
should move and take on a bigger
mortgage well how big of a room does a
baby need I'm
curious well I mean we would just like
for him to have his own space um but
still if I have an office and our other
son and that baby oh so the are the
bedrooms being converted into
offices yes so right now I'm in a office
which would be our Nursery um and I
would move my office to our bedroom our
other son has a bedroom and then my
husband um was going to be like in a
room with no windows kind of in a just a
corner done that yeah that's not fun the
real question is what do the dollarss
and cents say sure so um with his new
income our household income is
$220,000 good um yeah our current
mortgage is about
210 um but it's worth about 275 so we've
only been here about two years um the
thing to that is we owned a house before
this one um and we were only there six
months after the basement leaked and the
r mold that was discovered after we
bought it um okay we moved and so now it
feels like we're just jumping from house
to house and are never going to get
ahead of we keep moving as the right we
are yeah so how sorry just for clarity
how long have you been in this current
house um two years two
years
um you know I hear what you're saying
and I think the internet has some
validity if you're working from home you
need to find a way to get steady
internet um not not to nerd out but can
you just do like a hotspot yeah for from
a cell phone kind of thing like I know
verise all the cell phone companies have
those mobile hotspot and um it's also
not offered in our area the thing that
prompted this call we got darling I was
wondering about that as well yeah they
had they came out today and said yeah
it's Not Gon to work for you like we're
in a pre rural part of town with a lot
of trees um so we've looked at pretty
much other could you could you work out
of like a local coffee shop or
co-working space nearby or anything like
that um so my I have a desktop phone so
I can't really pack that up and take it
with me my husband's on Zoom calls and
the whole agreement with him taking this
job was that he'd have so he's going to
be traveling and my thing with that like
was that he'd be home working so the
travel would kind of offset with him
being gone and us having young kids so
so you've been in this current home a
little more than 2 years so that kind of
gets you off the hook if there were any
gains on this what's the what's the
property like if you were to sell it
today what would you get for it what you
what would you take home from that sale
about um we take home about 60 between
what we owe on it and what we could sell
it for and what could you add with that
do you have other than your baby step
three do you have any other money
saved no um we should be we should
finalize baby step three by uh December
1st and we could stockpile cash and move
but with a baby coming in February we
just I I would prefer to be settled in
the house than bring our baby home yeah
look I get it here's here's what I think
you guys need to see I think that
there's like this ideal state that you
have but until you have the especially
my screen says that you want to move
into a bigger house like you want to
move up it's not like you're saying hey
we're going to move into something
that's around the same price we're just
going over here where there's internet
it sounds like you want to spend more
money have something bigger and until
you have them cuz I I don't know what
you're pricing at like what are you what
is the cost of the homes that you want
to move into that's the question yeah so
we were um my thing was like we've
already moved twice in the last three
years and I don't want to get into
another house just to move in two years
when we could afford it you know it just
feels like if we keep jumping from house
to house we're never going to get
ahead um so we were looking at about
like
$400,000 houses which would yeah pretty
much be like three times of the mortgage
that we're paying right now right feels
like it's going to eat up a whole lot of
your income on top of paying the
nanny yeah so My worry is you guys get
in there and you're like we have
internet but no margin and now we're
stressed out financially even making 220
which is a great income can easily
disappear with the current you know
housing market and taking on double the
mortgage and paying a nanny it very
quickly could disappear so I right my
heart says let's pause on this let's get
the new baby in this current home let's
make it work let's figure out a
temporary Internet situation and once
you're back home with the baby nice and
healthy let's start shopping for a new
house with more money in the bank at
that point but right now it feels like
you're going to rush into a decision and
then go this isn't the house either yeah
right that's my worry and we have no
idea what like our month to month is
going to look like he like he just
started this week we haven't gotten that
first paycheck so exactly it could yeah
time next year we could be in a totally
different position I mean you've got the
nanny who can stay with the kid like I
liked George George's idea of maybe you
can go someplace else and get the work
done that you need to get done that
requires the internet while you've got
the nanny on call you're paying for her
to be there anyway and and contact you
know the company that you work for that
he works for and say hey here's our
situation we can't can you help us
figure out an Internet situation out
here maybe they'll cover it maybe they
know of a way to do this check with your
neighbors see how they're getting
internet I can't imagine every single
person within a 10 m radius
has that kind of poor
connection but either way I think the
the main thing to get across Hannah is
something here something has to give you
know I think sometimes we want to have
everything all at once it's like oh I'd
love for the baby to come home to a new
house I've got this new income and I
also think George that uh here's what I
think it's a lifestyle creep thing it's
like oh we finally got this new money
and we can just like we're like so quick
to spend it it's like just let it
breathe for a second like get used to
what life looks like well because
they're not you know I didn't hear about
investing or anything but we're at baby
step 3 we still need to have 15% to
invest we need to put money away for the
kids college we need to pay this house
off early so My worry is you're stuck in
this baby step 3 no man's land forever
because of that lifestyle creep so I
think we can find solutions for
everything the desktop phone usually
they can route that to hit your cell
phone yeah and you can use that or they
can issue a company phone you know
that's mobile so you don't have to Lug
your phone to a coffee shop or a
co-working space or whatever but in this
new fangled you know remote world I feel
like there's more options and we just
need to do some homework yeah I agree
with that um I agree with that
wholeheartedly thanks for the call that
was a good that's that's a good one to
think about I think you know there was a
lot going on there $220,000 that is a
great income but it's not it's not a
million dollars and it's not you know
half a million dollars like that can get
dwindled away very quickly on very big
expenses like if they move into a house
that they're not quite ready to afford
they can be one of those people who's
living p paycheck to paycheck who's
making over six figures cuz that's what
three one out of three folks making six
figures still paycheck to paycheck yeah
and that's sad largely due to Lifestyle
creep yep that's right and debt a lot of
Lifestyle creep too that's right that's
right this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
what's going on you guys are listening
to the Ramsey Show I am Jade warshaw
joined by George camel fellow Ramsey
personality and host we're taking your
calls all afternoon the number is8 825
5225 give us a call we used to say the
number was tollfree but I think these
days just about every call you make is
going to be a free one you never know I
might start charging one of these days
for fun if if you're if you're a a
nuisance of a caller bet you owe us a
dollar for our time ooh don't start all
right let's go to Stacy and Virginia
Beach Virginia what's going on
Stacy good afternoon good afternoon how
are
you um I'm okay um I have a issue I have
about um $30,000 in debt that I
just since Co I've you know tried paying
it and I put it in a um with a
consolidation company and I've just
within the past couple of months it's
like impossible for me to get it down
any further and I've been paying for
this would be the fourth year um so I
paid it off a huge amount of it but this
last 30,000 and I'm like $3500 behind
now and because of work situation
changing and everything is it I don't
know what to do it well
um a few years ago um two it's credit
card it's it's all credit card um um two
of our daughters were going through
really really bad times and I was making
good money and um had excellent credit
in the 800s and I gave them each a
credit card one of them two of them in
their name but still on my my credit and
their situation said when you say in
their name but so it was it's your name
okay their name so you just gave them a
credit card that was they were like an
authorized user but on your account
correct okay correct and
um unfortunately you know broken
promises and um it it just hasn't
happened so I ended up putting um once I
found out that they were not making
their payments um I tried to keep up
with it as best as I could but because
they had been late and stuff um it
snowballed and one of them even used it
for like rent cash advances so did you
take them off of these
cards oh yeah okay great so there's no
more debt being accumulated but you're
on the hook and they're not paying
another dime MH yes and I've paid um Al
together it was um with now this is with
the interest and the fees and everything
um it got up to
135,000 shees wait
wow yeah I paid everything but um this
last 30,000 you got it from 135 down to
down to 30 do you have any other
debt no okay and what's your household
income well see that's the thing my
husband does not know that I'm paying
this girl boy he doesn't know about the
debt he would disown them it would
totally fracture our family and
um he's gonna find out one
day um no no because we we don't have
debt except for the
only uh so you have to use your own
income and do this secretly with your
own bank account because he can't find
out because it would destroy the family
let me hold on a second can you flip the
script for a second and imagine the
table returned and your husband had done
what you did and took out these credit
cards and you know so on and so forth
well no he knew he knew they had he knew
that they had them he thought he thinks
that they're making their payment either
way either way if the tables returned
and he knew what you know right like
just put yourself in his shoes would you
want to be
told um if it wouldn't be that I know he
will disown them and no
simple question would if it would you
want to know do you feel like you would
have the right to know if you as a
couple had incurred
$135,000 of debt do you have the right
to
know you sure yes ma'am and here's the
thing if he disown them that's a
decision he made MH so you can own your
part you did a lot of stupid stuff but
it's up to him what he does with this
situation yeah and but that would mean
me not getting to see my grandchildren
no it
wouldn't oh sure it would because both
of them would take it you know the
opposite they would take it as you
tattled on dad to us and now I'm not
goingon to you're not our mom anymore
and you're not going to get to see the
kids as punishment exactly look if
that's how this whole thing's going to
go down there's not much of a
relationship there to begin with yeah
how are you already not resentful
towards the
daughters um I'm pretty sad this
relationship can't be in great shape
right now as it stands well there
circumstances that led to it and there's
no excuse that if they could and I had
put it in my email they're not in a
position they're literally just getting
by what they the initial you know that
they
did it's there's no excuse for it
because it shouldn't have been hidden
from me because then I could have done
something to help to rectify at that
time they they're their own women how
old were they when when this were taking
place over
18 oh yes I think but they were both one
one was getting out of a she didn't know
um she was relocating for her job went
up there the whole family was supposed
to move up when kids got Summer and the
now ex-husband decided he wasn't moving
and you know and the other was in a
horrible abusive marriage here's the
thing here's here's what I want to say
all those things are really difficult
those are difficult situations to manage
you're their mom you want to step in and
help you helped in the wrong way and now
everybody's reaping the results of that
and in this case the consequences of
that if you wanted to help you could
have given them a gift you could have
said hey I you know the the right way to
help in these situations is not to open
a line of credit where they can spend
and spend it's to say you know what I'm
going to cover your rent this month or
I'm you know and you're you're taking
the action yourself and you you still
got all the power in the control um as
far as the money and they can't create
debt on your behalf so yeah I think that
the hard part here is you're having to
come to grips with like this I tried to
help and I botched it and it's still
like it's still reaping bad fruit and
that sucks and I think also it's easy
for you to say oh my husband he'll dis
own them and he'll do this and he'll do
that and keep it from him but you guys
have all you've all got to get in a room
and be like this is what's going on and
it might be an episode of Jerry Springer
but you guys can't keep all these
secrets off to the side and dad doesn't
know this and Mom if you tell them
you're disloyal there's no healthy
boundaries here and there's no healthy
relationship taking place here man I
wish John deloney was here because he
would get up get up all into this this
is largely relational but the thing is
here you have you said you're having
work issues do you have an income right
now yes
but due to coid and and it's still where
we live it's still not 100% open back up
and to do Virginia's not open where what
I do with my job and I can't say or else
then that just pinpoints me okay um so
my income has dropped drastically what
do you make today past couple of years
um geez probably only like 30,000 right
now you need to go find a new
career well I've been trying I I
probably put in a dozen to two dozen if
you go work a retail job at $16 an hour
you just got a
raise when what does your husband
make
um good money due to six figures career
his career and you guys have totally
separate
finances no we have joint also but this
was on my own okay well you're not going
to going to be able to pay off this
$30,000 you need his help right now
unfortunately and which means you're
going to have to go and say listen I'm
sorry I committed Financial infidelity I
need your help fixing this I want to
salvage the relationships I need your
help this is what marriage is deal with
the hard stuff together yeah she's going
to have to she's going to have to
swallow her pride and go in there and
ask for help this is her spouse and by
the way combining incomes doesn't mean
that you have a joint account that you
both put some into and then you have
your separate accounts off to the side
that's not combining finances that's
playing yourself and you're playing your
marriage too this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the ramsy baby steps
go to ramseys solutions.com and click
the get started button button we'll help
you figure out the best next step for
you based on your specific situation
that's ramseys solutions.com and click
get
[Music]
started live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host today Jade
warshaw I am joined by one of my
favorite guys I mean George camel what a
stand-up individual you are so kind and
we're taking your calls all afternoon
about your life your money give us a
call the number Isle
88255 225 and we'll try to get you on
the line in the meantime let's quickly
go to these phone lines because we've
got Linda waiting in White Plains New
New York what's going on
Linda hi thank you so much for taking my
call happy to do so what's going
on so my parents are retired and they're
in the process of getting
divorced um my mom is going to be
keeping the house but she won't have
very much to live on so my siblings and
I um are thinking of taking on the
mortgage and my question is does it make
sense for us to take on the mortgage for
this house that's older and it needs
significant Renovations or should we try
to sell and find my mom a new place to
live I'm going for option number two
because it's way
cleaner I'm just IM like when you
started talking about that my brain
started imagining all the ways that can
go south because how many siblings is
it um there's three of us will be able
to take on that responsibility so let's
just pretend you guys split the mortgage
equally and then then suddenly one
sibling falls on hard times or something
happens in their world and they're not
able to hold up their end of the bargain
and so now it's falls on two siblings
and then God forbid something happens
and another sibling goes through
something with their life and their
family and they realize hey this is not
a priority do you see how that can kind
of unravel very
quickly yeah definitely that the what
we've been thinking though is even if we
try to buy something new we'll still all
have to pitch in um so it's kind of what
is her retirement income ways yeah uh
it's not much um so with social
security um my mom will have about
2800 that's something it's just her and
yeah she can't afford an apartment that
is sorry she can't afford a condo or an
apartment not in New York does she have
to live in do all the siblings live in
the White Plains
area yeah we pretty much all live in the
same area we consider relocating but
like for the entire family to relocate
that that would be significant is there
any spousal support what's going to
happen what's how's the dust going to
settle from this divorce as far as the
finances
go yeah so pretty much splitting my
dad's pension in half um but he has more
Social Security because he was the one
working so he'll be able to live on what
what he gets but my mom won't quite be
able to make ends meet so she'll have
the 2,800 plus half of his
pension no that is that's including that
includes the pension okay so if you were
to sell the house what would it
bring um in the condition that is
now maybe 100
150,000 it would only go for 50
Grand because it lot of Renovations then
I think we need to get her out of there
anyways
yeah what's going to happen when you
take on a big mortgage and you have to
pay for all these Renovations and none
of you even live
there yeah well um you know we're all in
our 30s we've all been saving for our
own homes so what we're thinking is
we'll just keep renting and and so
you're going to delay the rest of your
financial future to keep mom living this
dream SL
nightmare I would sell it and I'd get
her a real uh you know real just quaint
little an apartment M and if that can
get her mortgage lower to where she can
still afford it then that's great but I
would not refinance this thing and you
guys take on the loan but her name's on
the title it's going to implode the
family sooner rather than later what's
your net
worth um my net worth is about uh it's
probably about
150,000 yeah and if you had to guess
your siblings where are they sitting at
if you had to
guess oh somewhat less than that I don't
know what their net worth is but they
make about 60,000 a year and they
probably have they probably have that
average debt that sort of thing I'd
rather mom go live with one of the
siblings at this point ohe could she
live with one of
y'all um yeah yeah that's definitely
possible it's it's just hard for us to
think of you know our mom having to move
back into an apartment she loves being
outdoors she loves gardening she has two
big dogs she can still go outside and
she can still like there's so much that
she can still do I think you guys have
to grieve what's taken place and grieve
the fact that you guys all had this
ideal picture of what your mom would be
doing at this age and what that would
look like and that it's not like that
everything can I also just say she
doesn't get to have her dreams when she
did nothing to prepare for those
dreams that's a hard thing to say out
loud because I'm sure she's a wonderful
person an amazing mother but she's
sitting here with a mortgage no
retirement and hoping to live off of
Social
Security and so we have to also face
reality as John deloney would say one of
his daily decisions we have to make is
choose reality and the reality is she
can't afford the life that she wants and
you guys are going to prop it up while
setting back your own Financial Futures
which is only going to build resentment
and only takes one of these Jenga blocks
to fall one of the siblings to go this
sucks I'm out to where everyone hates
each
other yeah I think here I liked GE I
liked George's idea of possibly her
living with you guys for a while here's
what I'm thinking and you can poke holes
in this if you sell this house um and
you get 150 out of it I'm get now when I
asked you what would it bring I wanted
to know like what would you profit from
it not what so 150 is what you would
profit from it if I were you guys I'd
set that money aside and let it grow for
her and if you guys can work out a
situation where it's like Mom is living
with sibling one for a while and then
she's living with sibling to and maybe
over time you guys are able to figure
out a situation where she gets a little
apartment because she can draw some
money off of her nest egg and then she's
got the 2,800 coming in and then she's
kind of sustainable on her own but I
would rather you guys work out a
situation on the front end that doesn't
involve you guys each ponying up a bunch
of cash you know and this long-term
thing of we're paying her rent or we're
paying her mortgage I just think that
that's going to drain all of
you
yeah yeah that that that sounds good I
mean there will definitely we will still
have to contribute to her because again
with that income that she'll have she
won't be able to rent but like on her
own
um but yeah that's definitely I would
also do some homework and see what all
of the options are I know white Plaines
is expensive M but I would be shocked if
there wasn't a one bedroom for $2,000
$2,300 and maybe chip in to help cover
some of her groceries
mhm but we don't know how long we're
going to have to prop her lifestyle up
for I know that's right or maybe you
know maybe there's maybe there's a
friend or somebody else where she can
get a roommate situation and they have a
Golden Girls deal going on and they're
just you know they find a way you know
they've got a companion they're having
fun and they're living in their
apartment life together either way the
vision that they had for their mom is
going to have to change and that's tough
I hate to have to tell them that but
yeah option A and B aren't great let's
look at CDE e f and then make a decision
as a family and I bet the further out
they go there's going to be something
cheaper they've just got to look for it
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
thank you for listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm Jade warshaw joined by George
camel fellow Ramsey personality and uh
if you're a new listener to our show
number one thank you for being here
we're excited that you're here um and
number two you might hear us talk about
things that you're not quite sure about
we talk about a series of baby steps we
talk about something called FPU
Financial Peace University you might
hear us mention the word every dollar
and you're like what the heck is that a
budgeting app and you want to know more
information well we've got just the
thing for you we want you to head over
to ramsy solutions.com and we want you
to click on the get started button
that's going to help you find your best
next step here with Ramsey it's going to
help you get plugged in to what's going
to be the next step for you and that's
what we want want you to do so ramseys
solutions.com and click the get started
button today's question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services neighborly has top quality
providers like Precision Door Service
Junk King and more to help you take care
of projects before the weather gets too
cold so find the local help you need by
downloading the neighborly app today
today's question comes from Nick in
Georgia my wife and I bought a car new
last year for 34 Grand since having a
new baby and her becoming a stay-at-home
mom we were thinking of selling that car
for what we owe on it 27,000 and
purchasing a used car with 60 or 70,000
M for around 12,000 the other plan is to
attack the debt with intensity and pay
it off in 6 to 8 months I'm just
thinking it sounds better to save the
15,000 in cash this is our only debt
besides our mortgage and I wanted to get
your thoughts on trading the newer car
with the warranty the Kia for a Nissan
Versa or other small cars monthly
payment is$ 650 before extra payments
and we make roughly $140,000 a year with
a bonus
H love questions like these George fun
times yeah it feels like one of these
like riddles you had in in school back
in the day like stac has four apples yes
oh man Nick okay um if I'm in your shoes
I make 140k I've got 27,000 a payoff
this car is not too much for your world
sometimes we go hey dude sell the car
you make 50 Grand and this car is3 4
grand yeah so we're not going to yell at
you for the the car's value I'll yell at
you for taking out a loan in the first
place but making 140k you can pay it off
in 6 months I'd probably go that route
uh
versus trying to do the hoopla I'm going
to sell this you have Zer doar so you
still need the 12K to get the other car
so that's the that's the scenario here
yeah normally I'm in favor of
downgrading in car but it's not a
necessary piece of the equation I'm with
you on that what's really mon hurts my
heart it hurts my heart oh that car
needs to make like a tree and leave it's
really expensive $650 a month hurts my
heart I don't know how much money they
have in the bank if they had the money
in the bank right now to be done with
the debt and get that car you want to
know what consider it there's part of me
that thinks that they might have some
money in the bank cuz with all the det
sometimes we get questions of the day
there's like no details and I'm like
what is wrong this guy has every Det so
he sounds like a planner and like a
little bit nerdy like maybe a spend like
a knows where every dollar goes so if
they have some money sitting aside
people making 140k generally have a
little bit of money sitting aside now
some are living paycheck to paycheck but
a lot of times they're just doing 14
things at once yeah so I'm guessing I'm
guessing they could pay this thing off
even faster and so I like the hey if we
could pay pay this off in four months
instead of six or eight let's do it
let's go hard at this thing uh then I'm
okay with you keeping it but there's no
hard line I'm gonna draw here and go you
gotta sell it yeah uh because you know
smaller car new baby I don't know I feel
like you're just going to then turn
around and go well the car wasn't big
enough no yeah they can have this paid
off in a year so it's yeah no biggie
there I like it good advice George uh
what do you say we pick up s's call in
sou Falls South Dakota what's going on
S hey guys how are you doing good how
are
you oh I'm a little nervous but here we
go you got this you can do it oh thank
you uh so I read that to M make cover
and I got a very impulsive and I
basically empty our savings to wipe out
uh our cars uh my student loans and uh a
huge chunks to the mortgage okay how
much money was
that H man it was like over 40 K Over
40K yeah the problem is I did all this
without telling my wife
oh foul and Y penalty I really hurt yeah
I really hurt her feelings so you told
her now what was her reaction to this
obviously she's hurt but she she just
said she would have loved to uh be part
of the plan and and all this like I'm
usually in chch she a stay home mom and
uh I'm in charge of the finances and uh
run that back wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait let's hold up
go
um I think there's where the problem
lies there's this idea in your house
that you're in charge of the finances
and I think that's the mindset that led
you to think I read The Total Money
Makeover I got a great idea I'm going to
go into our savings and I'm going to pay
the
bills and that's what's gotten you here
and I think that starting instantly
right now you're doing a vocab rehab and
from now on the both of you are managing
the money it's our responsibility to
manage our
money can we agree on
that yes and uh so that was my question
how do I introduce her to you guys in a
very love loving and patient and kindly
way
um without coming as a control trick
like I realized there's a lot of
conviction in me now I I been showing
her like more like statements and
numbers and where our investments are
for through my employer like my 401k and
everything good and I realized that she
was not even aware of that and he broke
me like it's like no we're we're a team
like there's no it's not my money it's
our money it's our resources we take
trips together we we invest together we
grow together like we're a family mhm
you know do do you think that she wants
to like has has anything happened that
you feel like there's resistance like
she doesn't want to be involved or she
doesn't want to know or do you think
it's just been her her being in the role
she she thinks she's supposed to be in
and you being in the role you think
you're supposed to be
in I I think it's on me I think it's
my my lack
of uh leadership like showing her things
and
and like we don't do a budget I mean we
spend less than what I bring home and I
can see that because our savings were
growing every month but I I feel like
it's on me and uh
really um fully knowing how to include
her yeah on on the budget or I we're not
really doing a budget but I I I want to
start doing that well I'd love to if you
think that you can get her to watch it
with you I'd love for us to give you
Financial Peace University and you guys
watch it together I'd love for you to
find an in-person class near you and for
both of you guys to go to this class
together and make it a date night like
this is what you go and do you're in
participating together you talk about it
afterwards um and have every dollar part
of that so the way our resources are set
up they're set up for you to work
together every dollar is an app that you
download on both of your phones you both
can look at it financial piece it is
very uh of course you can do it if
you're a single but it I feel like
there's it's great for couples like it's
got that special piece to it so if we
give that to you s will you will you do
it
together oh absolutely all right
absolutely okay so you seem very Genuine
s and there's genuine remorse here and I
think that is going to go the furthest
with her of saying Hey listen I screwed
up I haven't been doing a good job
leading uh this house being a good
husband and I want to get us on the same
page and I want to let you know that
your vote counts just as much as mine
yeah yeah and I'm no longer just gonna
run this ship on my own and then just
let you know what I did in hindsight cuz
the heart behind it of he went and paid
off debt it's such a great thing wrong
way yeah I literally don't think it was
intentionally to be malice like I think
people enter into relationships with
like gender role ideas and a lot of guys
think hey it's my job or in some
families it's the woman who pays the
bills and it's like this is you and this
is me and this is just the way it's
always been but that changes today vocab
rehab guys this is we this has been a
theme Today George S hang on the line
we're going to gift you one year of
Financial Peace University as well as
one year of every dollar premium let her
have a say in the budget let her share
her thoughts on how you're going to move
forward and that will get you guys
dreaming together and get this marriage
back on the right foot this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for listening to the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Jade warshaw next to
me is George camel host of the YouTube
show George Campbell the George Campbell
show with a K don't wear it out that's
right and don't get confused about it um
we're taking your calls all afternoon
about your life and your money so give
us a call the number Isle
8825 5225 and we would love to chop it
up with you and that's what we're going
to do with Christian who's in Chicago
Illinois what's going on Christian
nothing much how are you guys doing
great
wonderful um so here is the scenario we
had our home up on the market uh since
for about three to four months um it was
under contract we were a week uh we were
the week of to close and then the buyer
lender did not approve their loan so
they weren't able to uh buy the house so
we put it back on the market
again we went under contract and then
the buyer backed out so we were supposed
to close on our third contract
yesterday now the buyer is short
$88,000 and we don't know what to do at
this point um don't know if to keep
waiting to to is there anything that we
could
negotiate um is is it's a roller coaster
we're really just trying to move forward
uh with our lives not sure
well first of all we're going to give
you advice as entertainment because this
is the job of you know the real estate
agent the closing attorney the lender
but we can give you our take if that
helps sure um so they're eight grand
short what has the communication been
because the the lender and the closing
office they should be looking at their
finances at the very last minute going
hey we still good we still good we still
good there hasn't been any Financial
changes so they had this money at one
point right
asked that question one more did they
have the a grand at one point or did
they never have it and they just got
pre-approved well that's yes but they
the apparently the buyer gave uh gave a
bank statement that was from August and
they went forward with it and in the
matter of three months the buyer who has
a joint account with her mother quot as
my attorney um whose mom spent 8,000 I
don't know it's it's probably personal
but it definitely did affect uh everyone
in the in the pipeline so well man if if
they got to pay to play and if they
can't this Deal's over and you're gonna
have to try for the fourth time which
sucks yeah what has the communication
been about when and if they're going to
close this deal and have the eight
grand well it sounded pretty consistent
it sounded pretty diligent um uh I would
need in writing that on this date we
will close and you will have the money
that's what we have on file everything
is ready to go tomorrow we're closing
and yesterday came um I got a phone call
five 5:00 that uh we're going to have to
reconvene because of it really sounds
fishy to me because apparently there's a
wire transfer coming in from Mexico oh
yikes cover the cost
Christian I don't like any of this I
mean you're doing this all by the book
right you're working with closing
attorneys and lenders and real estate
agents yes this isn't something like
Backwoods deal no this is a Dave Ramsey
realtor that that we found um a previous
attorney that I used to buy the house
okay I just wanted to make sure this
wasn't some weird situation where you're
kind of working around some of that
Christian what's what's your timeline I
mean do you have a contingent offer out
on another house or do you have some
time to you know what's your rush or do
you have a rush
well at this point it's it's getting to
a point where this is going to be like
the fourth fifth time doing it getting I
don't know it's it's tough it's tough to
to say because where are you guys going
to go let's say you close three weeks
from now where do you guys go well right
now uh we are we are staying with uh our
my in-law my mother-in-law um until this
all clears out we don't want to sign a
lease until this is you know
finalized um because we want to restart
we're um I've been listening to Dave
Ramsey and um I felt like this was the
right decision to make and this is you
know trying to restart save up a bunch
of cash and and get a mortgage that we
can you know afford sure so the that the
timeline is based off of that but on the
flip side we did just find out uh that
we have baby number two on the way
congrats so the timelight the timeline
is within that uh uh uh context you know
getting getting an apartment before the
baby comes and uh don't know if I'm
going to have to put the house on the
market again because you know logically
speaking it would probably be better to
keep it at that point but well again
here's the thing I
mean th this deal is not going to happen
it can't hurt you to put the house on
the market and keep it out there um
obviously we're going into winter time
and my guess is in Chicago things slow
down quite a bit in the winter am I
right yes yeah um I mean I would keep
working with that real estate agent
here's the thing and you can correct me
here uh when Sam and I were selling our
house something that was frustrating to
me is sometimes the realtor would act
like there was a solid offer and then
I'm like Sam and I are like yes we've
got this offer and then the next day
it's like oh well they pulled it back
and it's like how solid was it to begin
with you know what I mean so you might
also be dealing with that idea because
the Realtors they want to sound like
they're doing the best job for you and
I've got four offers and D D D D and
then at the end of the day they pull out
and you're like wait how how far along
really was it or were you just trying to
make it sound like you sold our house
super fast kind of thing so
just I'm curious what the uh real estate
attorney said have they talked through
the options like hey we can postpone the
closing we could work out a partial
payment plan they pay some of it now and
some of it after the fact we Clos the
deal what are the options that have been
laid
out um that's a good question he did I
spoke to them I spoke to the attorney
within the past couple hours and he said
that um the first option uh we wait
until she scraps it up he's hoping he's
just telling me a lot of things that he
hopes you know he hopes this hopes that
which isn't you know isn't convincing
enough for me really um um and the
second option was to I forgot what the
second option was to be completely
honest but it there wasn't a lot I mean
has anyone just suggested to push the
closing date by you know two weeks or
four weeks until this person can get
what do whatever they're going to do to
get the money thank you that was
actually the second option to to push it
back two to three weeks that I'm I'm
good waiting two to three weeks before
putting it back on the market in case
the deal does go through and you can be
done with this cuz I know you're just
exhausted at this point I bet I would be
too but beyond that I'd have an in
writing hey three weeks from now if they
don't have it we're moving on we're not
because it's gonna they're going to keep
kicking the can down the road yeah we
need another week we need another week
what do we do with the with our mortgage
then if you if the deal falls through
and you still have the
mortgage is that what you're saying yeah
well are you still going to list it
again at that point or you going to keep
the house and just live in it for a
while um we'll see I guess I guess we'll
see because right now there's a payoff
request so I I I don't intend to you
know pay the mortgage until the deal
closes do you have the money to pay it
off now or no no this is contingent on
the home
sale yes okay
yeah I mean the request doesn't mean
much until you actually pay it off so
right you're all good there I mean as
long as you're making the payments you
got to keep making that mortgage payment
until you figure out what's next yeah
and that's all you can do I mean you're
either going to decide to put it back on
the market again if this thing doesn't
come through in three weeks or four
weeks or whatever you decide as the next
close date or you you know you might
decide hey winter it's not going to be
good we're going to wait till spring to
relist it again you know how what
percentage of your take-home pay is this
mortgage right now are you guys
drowning um yeah um I don't know how to
do the math on that with the it's one I
have
$157,000 left on the loan um I'm
bringing home about 3,800 a month what's
the actual mortgage payment yeah oh the
actual mortgage payment is
1,200 okay yeah so it's not crushing
you so if this doesn't work out if this
doesn't work out you know in the next
four weeks you know it I would just
really consult with the realtor and say
what do you think is best we've been
down this road for you know for the last
real wants to close the deal they want
that commission but I know that's right
I'm going let's get this in writing with
the attorney and say they got three
weeks if it's not in three weeks they
lose their earnest money their deposit
and we move on with our life yeah but
are you going back on the market after
that or are you holding out till spring
I'm probably holding out cuz I think
they need a breath of air right now
they're exhaust oo tough stuff tough
stuff this is the Ramsey
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show our
scripture and quote of the day set your
minds on things above not on Earthly
things that's Colossians 3:2 then Frank
zap Zappa says a mind is like a
parachute it doesn't work if it's not
open ooh ooh my drop I like that okay
I'm Jade warshaw this is George camel
we're taking your calls we got a little
bit of time left today so try to get
your call in on those phone lines it's
8825 5225 and we take your calls live
and in person if anybody was wondering
about that uh let's go to Chicago we've
got brle on the line what's going on
brle hi thanks for taking my call um I'm
in a situation where um I want to move
out of my mom's house I want to get an
apartment or a house
my mom's very adamant about me you know
um not renting an apartment that's on
the first floor and she says that it' be
better for me to just stay in the house
and save money for a down payment and um
from my point of view I I want to move
out as soon as I can and um I'm taking
care of my financials so I can prepare
for that uhuh and I was just wondering
what your opinion of that is how old are
you 28 boy it's time to get out out have
you been working did you go to college
have you been working what have you been
doing yeah um I've been working at the
company I met right now for uh it's
gonna be two years in November
1 okay and what was the reason you were
staying home in the first place you know
after you got the job you had a big boy
salary was it hey I'm trying to pay off
debt or hey rent's
expensive right um my my mom's a single
mother it's just me and her here and the
rest of the family is back home and so
kind of been hesitant to leave her see
I'm wondering if there's a relational
piece of this where she just doesn't
want her son to leave because she's like
she likes having you around which is a
very sweet also trying to look out for
me financially too which I'm trying to
solve as well what do you mean
financially um I've got a couple debts
that I'm trying to pay off um so I take
home I take home monthly about 4,100
uhhuh um I had a credit card balance of
6,000 and it's down to
$375 now okay awesome so that's gone
like in the next few weeks right yeah
what else I have a motorcycle loan
that's got $10,100 and I'm planning on
selling that and just getting rid of it
and staying off of it are will you earn
a profit when you sell it or will you be
upside down or will it just be even uh
probably five to ,000 profit
okay um I have a card that we're
debating right out if whether or not for
me to keep it or not I bought it brand
new when I first got my job um it was
the loan amount was originally
36,000 and it's now down to 20 23 23,300
what's it
worth um py Blue Book trade in the
dealership was offering me
24 um I've been listenting it for
anywhere between 28 to
30,000 okay what else
um I have a student loan that's
11,000 okay so let's assume the credit
card's gone this month right and then
after that you said you're going to sell
the motorcycle and probably bring
anywhere between $1,000 to $5,000 if you
did that whatever profit that turned
would go onto your student loan and then
we've got to decide what's going to
happen with this car are you looking to
quickly pay it off or are you looking to
sell it in downsize to Something in
Cas um I was just going to sell it and I
have a car available for me right now
it's a Toyota that's got 130,000 miles
that I used to drive that my mother now
drives and she also has the opportunity
to go back to her older car that she
used to drive so she's got two
cars uh my yeah my my mom helped me buy
my first car the Toyota okay and D I'm
doing all of this cuz on paper you're
almost debt free if you do all this you
pay off the card we're going to sell the
motorcycle come out of that with 500 to
a000 Bucks sell the car for 30 you owe
23 you're going to make 6 or seven there
so you have seven plus the Thousand from
the motorcycle now we got eight to throw
at 11,000 of student loans and you're
debt free in the next two months yeah
and then you can actually move
out so what is your opinion about um
getting an apartment or staying at home
and saving for a DA payment I would get
the apartment get the apartment dude
you've already stunted your growth long
enough even if you have to get some
roommates and it's a great way to start
out like this idea of living by yourself
right you know it's like let's let's dip
our toe into the water before we just
dive off the High Dive Right what's her
deal with the first floor apartment
cockroaches I I don't have a problem
with it my mother has a problem with it
as far as safety and you know oh if it's
you're in the first floor the robber is
going to go on the first floor I don't
buy any of this wait there's there's
some arguments to this you do have to
think super dangerous part no I'm in a
good neighborhood and the apartment that
I'm looking at is literally a two-minute
W from her house so it's a safe
neighborhood the only other reason I
wouldn't live on the first floor is
that's where the bugs come in is that
are you are you that person second floor
is the best floor you don't want to if
you go too high up no one's going to
help you move getting your couch up
there is going to be a pain in the butt
go hilarious thank you will Rudder will
Rudder in the booth knows what I'm
talking about but if you go on the first
floor if there is any pest issues on
that property they're going right under
the door into your I think we're done
letting Mommy make the decisions for us
that's the heart of all of us yeah
that's right that's right so I just
think we got to go mom I appreciate
everything you've done for me you've
been amazing I got to step out on my own
I've been making bad decisions while
living at home taking on all kinds of
debt I think using my own money my own
income not having this safety net this
hammock I've been laying in is going to
cause me to make better financial
decisions and therefore I will come
visit you on the weekends we'll have
family dinner love you so let's Sanara
let's let's talk on both sides of this
for coin uh for a second George so I've
been reading and there's a lot of
arguments out there why you know if
you're coming out of college or you're
you know in your TW early 20s it could
be beneficial for you to live at home
for a couple of years while you're
getting your financial footing or
whatnot this is this is what some of the
articles are saying but there's part of
you is like yeah you could do that if
you have a great relationship with your
family like I know a couple of people
who can actually live at home with their
parents and no one blows up I couldn't
do it but hey and there's like yeah you
know if you have that type of
relationship for a year or so that could
work but then there's part of it I'm
looking at my guy's numbers here and
there's part of it that's like I live at
home I don't have any expenses I can buy
motorcycles and cars and dilly dally
with my student loan this idea that I'll
save up a down payment like or just get
comfortable and slowly there we go is
that an M&M reference I
mean I had to knowing you I just thought
it was yeah you know but there there is
part of that where it's Comfort can
really hold you back 100% from doing
what you know that you need to do and
I'm not dogging on ble I'm having a
little bit of fun but I truly think that
when you step out on your own with your
own income your own bills and your
parents they did a great job raising you
yes but you're an adult now we have to
have our own life make our own decisions
and it's great to ask Mom for advice
when we need it but to have her dictate
hey here's what you're going to do next
at 28 I'm out on that yeah it's not good
and yeah even if you get a second floor
apartment which is I just have never
heard this second4 years old I've never
heard that you should not get a first
floor apartment I want anybody watching
this on YouTube to put in the comments
if it matters what floor you're on and
put the reason it matter because of your
neighbors like you know people stomping
above you like what's going on up there
that's true but when yeah you got to
think about these things you don't want
a bunch of people above you yeah but the
idea that robberies don't happen on
second floor Apartments I call BS on
that too yeah that's true and it sounds
like they live in a a safe neighborhood
but the point here is there can be some
benefit if you have just I think my rule
of thumb is like a year when you
graduate college you have a year to go
home have an exit strategy and then you
got to have an an exit and if life
happens you have some extenuating life
life circumstance it's okay to have that
safety that I got to be home for 6
months or a year get my life back
together but this is a different
situation I moved out when I was 20 and
moved across the country and I love my
parents and and I visit home but I just
had to I I it felt good I felt like it
propelled me into adulthood in a
different way than if I had lived at
home until I was you know 28 or 30 yeah
I moved out and I lived I moved into an
apartment that some girls I went to
school with and there was no room I just
slept on the couch and I lived there and
you survived I survived was it a first
floor it um no I don't think it was
first floor I don't really remember and
it wasn't I was sleeping on a couch you
know I think I was paying like a couple
of hundred dollars and then I got
married and Sam and I moved in together
so it worked out it worked out hey
that's what we're here for that is what
we're here for this has been the Ramsey
Show thanks for hanging out with us that
does it for this hour when it comes to
your life and your money you can tell me
that you won't do it but don't tell me
that you can't this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter